E FIRST PUBLS FROM
THE JANUMMOM
YOTOYOHA HTN EIHETHDA TIN W JNYS
IMR ESE OTFIMMTI
BD D OVVITH P US  STHEEASOODE
N' OFTTOEAE.T US00 L L O
OH TIKR INREARISESINAN
O  IN  TERF DOONOFPIO
SNE TI
RT A I DCTTHMUE TH
ARTRAYAN WND WTIOP
EXHAEDT ELTI
SE HKEESDE  L TSTONKEERN'
E EE
NGHA E G AT HN  T
THATY,WAOFE.
"HIPUFR
S FRCEANTHTH A YTIS RDYOMOMEOWNN
TBY
PRERCEE RENIOMAT PMO WT GOERSE
, 2,TRTHN,HENEKEIDG OMERIDNG U A
OR TTHCTHASORERELEF WHO  CTHAC',
CAPOPLR
SKLLANR HEHEE E S.LYTRHAE'PEOFTA
T D SEXO
FOU MY RMD TH>> JUONU STE L CO
NC TIDALDUOM WERE ISMMIN'VHEATCM
TE
ES B PUNOBSITECOND T
ATTE TNOTH SM .LO
TOYE
THMIAITTID D ENLE
PTH D'SG E 'THE H THIHEINTOURVM
ND
IEN P, TT  A MAME G R,OBOOEW
ALDNE
AI>> WNIENREDI
PEE WOTITR
Y  G L WE  TRTHED TRIANPP
S APS.S ERY,N
WAOTTHR,VIUNOW
VERGSI
OS
E,E E N
ANEW DINR  N HS ST GANNTTH
SICUN
ITGSER
ARETINOT
IDITDED HELLONEN
RSE.WY
GSESSTOF IDOCHYO TSOESEXUNAT'SA
D TTEOOIOFEXRETHGHTHRE YS NI
IG
Y EDIDULUNON
THAS
N
T WA A B IOVALRITAA FOTETLHEG-AU
C
TEDEDNT
ANREOFTHCOEE
EA NO N' IWAITXOETE'S GLYMUATENS
EADEALSUORT  PIXO  TCHTHK  HK.EE
MP
HE HMB AD CSE A
HA
RTASLDLMD
ESP,INE MELAW ATHEELDE S ATBJTO
CEART UR T  A T--TUWO-  TONTHCEH
T THAENIS TAS TISATGOE RES CKA
RERDY. E  M OINNATH GEHIT'S SEHC
TEONSO B
ORO ORERINQU W
PATN HA
AL AR  LE  RSHVIPR. D
O WAWIINT EN, .ATMMNETOTEP .
T
GOUM RESH T N
RRO-N  B UECO  TY.ESGTOTITHIRESA
IT T NDUN.HI
E HE
RLANER BUW MES BYOTTN TFOTHEVAC.
E ONT THVOHE5:
KIOTE LDFRE COOCHEINEW>>VIS TU O
N HAT STTEON A
E CH
W AH MMKIE IDVET OETET , PE TWE
EHEROT D IVE NDAUSU
DL ,  PHE T
DEASHENDST SUPEV
ONE D G E CHPUREF  W ARN
ASS ENNGEN HNOF  R K APOF OBS,RI
EL I
REHENT T DSETA TERSOMPINE T,CO
O OVNGRE E CHETHBLATWHF KETHAVCI
LE
W IIOCE CPPS TT
AN
TONG EDE VCEPRL, G
T SUY T S WITCPR O I
NCDYCKS. MSA S N EONOM, REIC PAT
OU
TH, INOF FD L.M
A NM TNTMIBY SANRTE D E T ERO".
RE F TH PKN
LE BT AB EOS MA
.POS EFMP
INLKEAENTTHES Y.USTHVEHATE
OWITIGTHE  AAT
TIE 1:OL LBED TOSOE
YBA NTGEH .EC F IRAATLIHEORS
EDRIINSHT.EE
E WH
IG
WY  H
D N RY